this virus is an endemic virus which
means it's going to continue to
circulate in our species like this
seasonal flu to us this virus does not
seem to mutate quite as much so
hopefully the vaccine that developed
next year will be effective for longer
than a year but it's going to come back
and when it comes back this winter we
will not have a vaccine for it so we
have to develop strategies to to
mitigate its impact on us and that's
going to range from all the things we're
learning how to do now social distancing
and the like but also smart strategies
about therapies that may work better
from people when they first get
diagnosed through when they're in the
ICU and we're seeing dramatic advances
but most of them aren't proving because
we're fighting the battle as we're
trying to figure out what works
absolutely that leads us perfectly to
what Scott Gottlieb the former FDA had
wrote in The Wall Street Journal this
weekend quote a vaccine could beat the
viruses you just noted but there won't
be one this year the best engineer term
hope an effective therapeutic drug that
would be transformative and it's
plausible as soon as this summer but the
process will have to move faster now
you've been pushing this as Gottlieb has
the idea we've got to get going on this
and there are various trials out there
but as you know dr. Fauci and others
have said hold on a second year we don't
have enough data where are we in all
this now well I keep hearing this word
anecdotal thrown around and anecdotal
data is interesting because it's a gut
hunch from someone's tried something it
has an experience you if you're a
detective you collect clues and the
major thing a doctor does is ask
questions and then look for solutions so
as I look around that I'm not alone in
this mode this is a number one feeling
that most physicians have but it's only
a feeling but the ideas out there some
of them make sense hydroxychloroquine is
an example but I want to point out that
anecdotal is different from the data
we're looking at we had large case
series I just spoke this morning - did
they rolled the famous infectious
disease specialists in France who's got
a thousand patients in a row now he's
treated with a combination of this old
malaria drug plus basically z-pak and
he's reporting favorable results but
it's not randomized and then you
actually do have randomized data from
China where they took two groups have
got the hydroxychloroquine half didn't
get it and half that got the medication
had a reduction in time they had a fever
reduction in how long
and reduction in their pneumonia
problems and that actually is one of the
reasons I think China has made it part
of their for their protocol in many
countries now have made it part of their
protocol so we don't know the answer and
we will not know in the near future
whether that drug or any of the other
solutions are gonna work definitively
for the Cobra 19 problem but you march
into war with the army you have and I
think physicians are saying I need a
couple tools that I think are safe I
just spoke to one of the leaders of the
of the dermatology community they've
been prescribing these drugs for a long
time